it seems like everyone wants to play the
witness but not everyone wants to pay
for it according to creator Jonathan
Blow the piracy is so bad that developer
thekla may not be able to make another
game some have cited the witnesses forty
dollar price tag as the reason for this
and others have said an early demo would
have made things better blow made a
counterpoint that braid only cost
fifteen bucks and had a demo beforehand
but still suffered from piracy taking to
Twitter he said it seems the witness is
the number one game on a certain popular
torrent site unfortunately this will not
help us afford to make another game I'm
glad that a lot more people will be
experiencing the game but I also want to
be able to make another comparable game
next just saying gamers certainly want
to get their hands on the witness
gamespot gave the puzzle game and nine
out of ten so we understand if Jonathan
Blow announces another game in the
future you'll hear about it from us for
now please support the developer as you
like